but because it's only three cameras we
only see one so this is not six cameras
no this was only three three with the so
if we go to the end you see our sister
coming in and getting your levels and
stuff hey everybody so they've
officially started rolling cameras on
the Shazam movie so I figured it was
time for an update they've been posting
videos from behind the scenes
and there's this rumored Henry Cavill
Superman cameo Zachary Levi himself is
also pushing for a Wonder Woman cameo
I'll explain why I think it's a little
more likely that Henry Cavill will show
up but just don't count out any of the
other more popular members of the
Justice League that fit with the tone of
Shazam it's all about tone who would be
more meaningful for that character and
especially if they're trying to be as
comic-book II as possible who amongst
the Justice League characters right now
has had the most interaction with him in
the comics and that would be Superman
and Wonder Woman in her current film
incarnation she's sort of like the
de-facto Superman while we don't have a
Superman around because they're kind of
in the same tone the working title as
you can see on the slate there is
Franklin the Easter Egg they're sort of
a joke on Benjamin Franklin being struck
by lightning the way that Shazam gets
struck by lightning but you could also
take it as a backdoor wink at the idea
of Franklin Pierce publisher of The
Daily Planet but if you guys didn't know
anything about what's going on with the
movie Mark Strong is playing the villain
he's going to be dr. sivana they're
doing his children from the comics it's
gonna be a little bit different we've
gotten some character descriptions but
just in general and the way that a lot
of these movies combine different errors
of the comic
expect them to pull from a lot of
Captain Marvel Fawcett comics era from
Marvel family stuff in all the way up
through the new 52 with the Marvel
family they've already cast most of the
kids that are part of the Marvel family
like they just cast Darla
they cast Freddie Freeman so we don't
know how crazy they're going to get with
the different powered members of the
Marvel family because all of them get
powers at various points but they might
wade into that because it does feel kind
of extreme that they all get powers and
I'm not talking about the crazy
flashpoint version of Shazam where Billy
Batson says the word Shazam and then
like all the Marvel family kids combine
into one Shazam
[Music]
captain Thunder I'm happy to see that a
real man is here to watch the end of
math I don't think they're gonna do
something crazy like that but you can
probably see behind the scenes
creatively they're going for that
it's stranger things vibe where you have
a group of kids that you follow around
so obviously Zachary Levi is playing the
adult version of Shazam when he has his
powers and he's walking around he's
already been beefing up we don't have a
costume reveal yet but this boss logic
picture is probably pretty close
obviously the colors aren't gonna be
quite so bright but I think what will
happen is is now that they've started
shooting is is they'll have enough
footage to cut a teaser that they'll
release either a comic-con like some
sort of logo reveal or a costume reel or
something like that and then they'll
release the first trailer when we get to
Aquaman in December so if you didn't
remember there is an Aquaman movie that
James Wan and Jason Momoa made that's
coming out in December
they've already actually said they've
addressed some of the issues that people
had with the Aquaman underwater scenes
during the Justice League movie remember
the scene where Mira created the bubble
so that she and Aquaman could talk to
each other normally because the sound
would sound so muffled underwater there
were a lot of people that came out of
that thinking about the Aquaman movie
and they're like wait a minute are they
gonna create a bubble
every time somebody needs to talk to
somebody else in that movie that is
gonna get exhausting and then James Wan
came out immediate was like no no no we
solved that problem right away he didn't
say what that solution was and we
probably won't find out till we get the
first trailer but I don't think that
that's too far off either but the whole
thing with Superman I've done a couple
videos about the Man of Steel sequel
they're still planning on making they're
just trying to lock down a director but
obviously they can't really say anything
until everybody signs their contracts
they're still trying to lock down their
director so we can talk about Man of
Steel specifically in another video but
the whole challenge that they have with
the character is is they just need to
remind everybody what he stands for
in it kinda came across and Justice
League but there was so much
going on with the mustache gate of it
all that people just kind of brushed
over a lot of that but the good thing
about Superman you know in this larger
DC movie universe which I guess is not
supposed to be called the DC EU is that
Geoff Johns said that even though
they're taking a more separated approach
the movies are still connected
meaning that Billy Batson would know
about Superman meaning that they could
still set up the same type of connection
that those characters have that they've
had in the comics as well as the
animated movies they've done so far the
clips from the Shazam movie that I
always include in the videos that I do
is mostly new 52 they're in the process
of locking down their wizard Shazam who
is probably going to be this actor here
you'll probably recognize him from Luke
Cage and a billion other things which i
think is a solid pick he's a great actor
but you can kind of see they really are
going new 52 with a lot of these things
at least with the look but obviously
they'll be a lot of classic stuff in
here too so what is the best way to get
people really excited about a Shazam
movie as well as remind them what the
Superman character stands for and the
fact that they can do a really cool
version of the Superman character well
you put Superman in the Shazam movie in
some fashion but obviously if that
really does end up happening I think
it'll be even less than what you saw of
Robert Downey jr. during spider-man
homecoming because we had all those
Ironman homecoming jokes that was even
that Robert Downey jr. poster because of
the way they marketed the film people
were like wait a minute is this an Iron
Man film or just a Spider Man film but
come to watch the movie and there's
really only a handful of scenes with
Tony Stark
so I think it's gonna be the same
situation with Superman where Billy
Batson grows up knowing about him having
seen everything that went down he sees
cellphone footage of Superman being a
hero doing really awesome stuff and that
sort of informs his sense of optimism
and when he gets his powers he also
eventually gets to meet him Superman
helps him out a little bit with his
problems but even though the animated
movie mostly hypes up the big battles
that they have together like the really
crazy heroics I think the diner scene is
a better example of how you use Superman
in a Shazam movie holy moley is this all
for me mr. Kent since you ate two
breakfasts yesterday I thought I better
order you three today
good and good will follow that's what my
parents used to always tell me but you
know mr. Kent I was good before they
were taken from me I was good at the
foster home and I was good 15 minutes
ago
I'm starting to think being good isn't
good for me it seems that way sometimes
doesn't it but that's because good is
hard where yeah he's Superman
he has all these badass powers but he's
more of a counselor reminding Billy
Batson what it is to be a hero without
actually having to beat the crap out of
a bunch of people the reason why a lot
of people were like what about Wonder
Woman though because she almost does the
exact same thing like she stands for a
lot of the same principles there's a
couple key differences between them and
that Wonder Woman wields a sword and
she's not afraid to kill people the way
that Superman is but in the public
consciousness right now she's one of the
few characters from the Justice League
that people are really crazy about and
she's got that sequel coming up so it
would make sense that there's also a
wink and a nod to her as well too but
the problem with big cameos like that
like including Wonder Woman and Superman
in this Shazam movie is that you have to
lock those actors down in Henry Cavill
for example is getting ready to do the
Mission Impossible 6 press tour and you
know people are talking about boycotting
the film because of all the moustache
gate problems if you don't know about
any of that stuff it's a fascinating
tale of two Studios just being dicks to
each other paramount being a dick about
Henry cavils moustache and Warner
Brothers trying to work around that for
the Justice League movie but barring any
really big action scenes usually stuff
like that like when you include those
actors that gets done at the last minute
they can add all that Superman and
Wonder Woman stuff much much later in
the process like it's the easiest thing
in the world for Clark to show up at
Billy Batson store you're probably not
going to see any exterior scenes of
Henry Cavill walking around on set in
the Superman costume on that movie so
just let me know in the comments
they put Superman and maybe Wonder Woman
as well in the Shazam movie how do you
want them to use those characters
without them overpowering the movie
there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and just share the video
using the tools on the watch page I'll
name a new winner when I post flash
stuff tomorrow obviously we have a new
flash episode coming up so whole bunch
of DC and Marvel
dropping this week click here to learn
all about that mystery character on the
flash and click here to learn all about
spider-man into the spider burst in
spider-man homecoming - thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
we'll see you guys tonight